En el referéndum sobre el Brexit los
gibraltareños eligieron permanecer en
la Unión Europea. En Reino Unido el
Brexit ganó por poco y algunas regiones
eligieron también quedarse en la Unión.
Pero lo de gibraltar fue de escándalo.
Casi todos los gibraltareños, un 96%,
decidieron quedarse en la Unión Europea.
Esto plantea un serio problema para
Gibraltar.
Si al final el Reino Unido sale de la
Unión, Gibraltar también tendrá que
abandonar su estatus
Tras el Brexit Gibraltar corre el riesgo cierto de
perder su relación especial con la
Unión Europea.
Esto significaría controles en la
frontera, un aislamiento del peñón y
perjuicios para toda la región del
Campo de Gibraltar.
¿Qué hacer entonces? En este vídeo vamos
a hablar de los problemas actuales de
Gibraltar y de su relación con España.
Y os aseguro que son cuestiones muy,
muy interesantes
En varios
momentos de la historia Gibraltar ha
querido ser independiente pero no ha
podido porque Naciones Unidas ha
declarado que tienen que respetarse los
derechos de España.
Gibraltar está en la lista de descolonización de Naciones Unidas pero su origen no fue la
expansión colonial. La ciudad el puerto
y el peñón de Gibraltar fueron una
cesión territorial de un estado europeo,
España, a otro, Gran Bretaña, hecha con
condiciones en el Tratado de Utrecht de
1713.
Una de esas condiciones es que en caso
de que Gran Bretaña quiera cambiar de
cualquier manera el estatus de Gibraltar
España recupera los derechos anteriores
a la cesión. Por esto
Reino Unido no puede transmitir el
territorio de gibraltar a ningún otro
estado y Gibraltar tampoco se puede
convertir en independiente. En cualquiera
de esos dos casos
españa tiene derecho a recuperar
Gibraltar. Poned atención,
esto es textualmente lo que dice él
tratado.
¿Un paraíso fiscal?
Frente a esta situación Londres dio
una Constitución otorgada a Gibraltar
en 2006 que respeta su autonomía pero
reserva las relaciones exteriores y la
seguridad para el Reino Unido. Un
gobernador de la reina comparte el poder
con el gobierno de Gibraltar
actualmente presidido por Fabián Picardo
del Partido Laborista. El Parlamento de
Gibraltar quienes solamente 17 escaños
y en la actualidad diez de estos
componen el gobierno presidido por
Picardo, con ministros como los señores
García, Cortés o la señora Sacramento.
Nombre muy mediterráneos.
Además, el gobierno de Picardo se
encuentra bajo la tutela del gobernador
militar británico que en la actualidad es Edward Davis.
El gobernador que no está sometido a
los tribunales puede, por ejemplo,
rechazar las normas aprobadas por el
Parlamento de Gibraltar si la reina no
las acepta o si el gobernador entiende
que son contrarias al buen gobierno del
territorio.
Al mismo tiempo Gibraltar tiene un
régimen especial en la Unión Europea.
Gibraltar no es territorio de la Unión
porque no es territorio del Reino Unido,
pero allí se aplica el derecho
comunitario y las libertades
comunitarias, salvo la unión aduanera.
Esto quiere decir que las importaciones desde fuera
de la Unión pagan impuestos en
cualquier territorio de la Unión,
pero las importaciones a Gibraltar no
deben pagar ese impuesto común.
Por este motivo las cosas importadas son
más baratas en Gibraltar, como por
ejemplo el tabaco o los productos del petróleo.
Gibraltar se ha aprovechado de
esta situación de varias maneras:
una de las primeras importaciones de
Gibraltar es el tabaco en grandes
cantidades. Pero los gibraltareños no pueden fumar
todo lo que importa. Por ejemplo, se calcula que en 2014 entre
un 30 y un 40% de el tabaco que llegaba
de contrabando a España
provenía de Gibraltar.
Y la Unión Europea y España dejaron de
recaudar alrededor de 1.000 millones de
euros por este concepto.
Desde entonces se ha regulado la venta
de tabaco y su entrada en España pero
todavía queda mucho por hacer.
Igualmente Gibraltar realiza pactos de
exención fiscal con empresas que se
instalan en su territorio, y muchas de
ellas con oficinas ficticias para poder
operar en países de la Unión Europea
sin pagar impuestos.
Fijaos bien con un territorio de unos
seis kilómetros cuadrados en Gibraltar
hay inscritas más de 20.000 empresas.
Esto ha sido duramente criticado por la
Comisión Europea que acusa a gibraltar
de competencia desleal.
Pero el caso más espectacular que
demuestra que Gibraltar ha querido ser
un paraíso fiscal es el de las empresas
de apuestas online.
Este caso es muy reciente ha sido
resuelto por el Tribunal de Justicia de
la Unión Europea en junio de 2017.
Lo más sorprendente de este caso es que
fue una demanda del Reino Unido contra
Gibraltar. La asociación de empresas del juego
había convencido al gobierno de
Gibraltar para no poner ningún impuesto
a los que ganaban apuestas online para
favorecer la instalación de estas
empresas mientras que en Reino Unido
los ganadores de apuestas online debían
pagar un 15 por ciento.
Pues bien, al final el Tribunal de la
Unión Europea dio la razón al Reino
Unido y Gibraltar ha tenido que aplicar
ese impuesto. Al final Gibraltar ha
perdido numerosos casos judiciales
porque quiere actuar como paraíso
fiscal, e incluso según algunos informes
aprovecharse de tráficos ilícitos.
Evidentemente esto afecta a la hacienda
y a la seguridad no sólo de España
sino de la Unión Europea.
En el referéndum sobre el Brexit se demostró
que los ciudadanos de Gibraltar tienen
intereses muy distintos a los del Reino Unido.
Para intentar una solución
temporal a la controversia sobre
Gibraltar, tras el Brexit España
presentó una propuesta de soberanía
compartida al Reino Unido en octubre de
2016 ante Naciones Unidas.
La idea principal es una soberanía
compartida de España y Reino Unido
sobre Gibraltar que mantendría su
autonomía sobre asuntos locales.
En esta propuesta se permite a los
gibraltareños guardar la nacionalidad
británica y adquirir además la
española, una gestión conjunta de la
seguridad y las relaciones exteriores y
la pertenencia de Gibraltar a la Unión Europea.
No se vosotros qué pensaréis, amigos de
VisualPolitik, o qué pensarán los
gibraltareños pero a mí me parece que
esta propuesta tiene tres grandes
ventajas:
Primero una normalización de las
relaciones de Gibraltar con su entorno y
la apertura de la frontera.
Segundo el relanzamiento económico del
Campo de Gibraltar y de toda la región
con el uso conjunto del aeropuerto.
Y tercero los gibraltareños ya no
tendrían que elegir entre o ser
británicos o ser españoles porque
pueden ser los dos y lo que es más
importante ser ciudadanos de la Unión
Europea.
En cambio el escenario opuesto, una
ruptura de relaciones con la Unión
Europea supondría mayores controles
fronterizos y un posible aislamiento del
peñón. Y esto afectaría por supuesto a
los más de ocho mil trabajadores que
desde España se desplazan cada día
para trabajar en el peñón.
En definitiva, sería malo para todos.
"Lo preocupante, bueno lo preocupante es que
haya fluidez en la frontera que es un
tema más Schengen que Brexit, pero ese ha
sido el pan nuestro de cada día de 35
años que llevamos con la frontera abierta".
La propuesta española de cosoberanía
subraya que se respetarían las
tradiciones y la cultura de Gibraltar.
Además, indica también que el régimen
nuevo de Gibraltar podría insertarse en
la Constitución española de 1978.
Hoy estamos delante del parlamento
español y bajo la estatua de Cervantes
y hemos venido aquí para encontrarnos
con Ainhoa López, licenciada en derecho
público y presidenta de la Asociación
Cultural Alonso Martinez:
Hola, Ainhoa ¿qué tal estás?
Quería preguntarte en primer lugar
las nacionalidades históricas y las
regiones, según menciona nuestra
Constitución, ¿cómo hicieron sus
estatutos de autonomía?
Pues, muy fácil a través del artículo 143 de la
Constitución se elaboró el marco para
que estas regiones y nacionalidades
elaborarán su propio estatuto y así se
conformarán cumpliendo los requisitos como
comunidades autónomas.
Y además de estos estatutos de las nacionalidades y
regiones, ¿existen otras posibilidades en
nuestra Constitución?
Sí, en el artículo
144 de la Constitución existe ese
apartado como para ciudades como Ceuta y Melilla.
Y en este sistema, ¿sería posible
integrar el caso de Gibraltar?
Sí claro, de hecho la Constitución lo
prevé así en el artículo 144, esa
amplitud está hecha precisamente para
poder implantar a Gibraltar dentro de
la Constitución.
Muchísimas gracias, Ainhoa, gracias
por estar con nosotros en VisualPolitik.
El artículo 144 de la Constitución
establece que las Cortes Generales
mediante ley orgánica pueden por
motivos de interés nacional autorizar o
acordar un estatuto de autonomía para
territorios que no estén integrados en
la organización provincial.
El Brexit, amigos inteligentes, plantea un reto muy
grave para Gibraltar. Sus ciudadanos y
sus empresas puedan quedar fuera de la
Unión y al margen de las libertades
comunitarias.
Los gibraltareños deben resolver la
contradicción en la que se encuentran
por un lado dicen que quieren ser
europeos y por otro han dicho que no
quieren que Reino Unido negocie la
cosoberanía con España.
Cuando en realidad tras el Brexit la única manera que los gibraltareños tienen de
regularizar su situación en la Unión
Europea es yendo de la mano de España.
Esta solución aportaría beneficios para todos.
Supondría el relanzamiento económico
de toda la región. Sobre todo hay que
evitar aislamientos y bloqueos, hay
soluciones ganadoras para todos. Para que
se entienda en la lengua de Shakespeare: "It´s a win win situation".
Gibraltar podría
aprovechar la propuesta española de
cosoberanía y buscar soluciones
imaginativas para resolver esta
controversia histórica entre España y
Reino Unido. En fin, Cervantes y
Shakespeare deberían entenderse como
buenos amigos.
Hasta la próxima, inteligentes.
mi mente
m